[Musique]
bonjour Fred lordordinau bonjour Maurice
violton bonjour à tous ceux qui nous
écoutent ce matin membre du Parti
progressiste Martinique est 4e
vice-président de l'Assemblée de
Martinique et depuis quelques temps Fred
lordordino depuis quelques temps soutien
au mouvement en marche d'Emmanuel Macron
candidat à la présidentielle française
depuis quand exactement ce soutient Fred
lordino c'est une réflexion que j'ai
mûri parce que j'ai regardé le paysage
politique que aujourd'hui Emmanuel
Macron me semble celui qui représente le
mieux les valeurs progressistes c'est un
jeune ce sera certainement le plus jeune
des candidats mais surtout il propose
aux Français et aux martiniquis une
véritable révolution notamment en
matière de gestion de l'État à dire vrai
l'annonce de votre soutien sucite des
questions notamment dans la garde
rapprochée du patron du PPM sergechimi
au sein des instances dirigeantes du
parti alors pourquoi alors que Serge
lachimi Johnny nijard le secrétaire
général roule plutôt pour Manuel Vals
pourquoi vous avec Macron parce que le
Parti progressiste n'est pas le parti de
la pensée unique vous savez que ce parti
est né d'un acte de rébellion porté par
le grand céser aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut
c'est un débat les martiniquis dans une
période qui est particulièrement
difficile avec les attentats terroristes
avec l'arrivée de nouveau président aux
États-Unis il y a un vrai danger mais il
y a surtout un autre danger c'est c'est
la possible arrivée en France à la
présidence de la République d'une
personne d'extrême droite il faut de
débat au sein du Parti progressiste
martiniqu il faut qu'il y ait du débat
au sein de la société martiniicaaise au
sein du parti d'ailleurs je vous sign je
vous signale que le parti luion question
il y a pas ce débat au SE du
partina les droits aux tendances et il y
a un vrai débat au parti puisque le
Congrès a
tranché en faveur d'une ligne mais les
autres lignes existent dans le part
Parti progressiste mais il y a surtout
la volonté d'un certain nombre de
militants progressistes comme moi de
moderniser les pratiques et aussi
l'idéologie du parti c'est fort ce que
vous dites là ce matin il faut
moderniser les pratiques on a
l'impression que lorsque vous parlez
comme ça fredordino que et ben les
choses sont un peu sclérosées au parti
de Trinel je comprends mal ou bien
dites-moi tout non il y a une défiance
des martiniica et des Français envers
tous les parti politique c'est la
réalité c'est pouro situation de frordin
au sein du
parord esprit libre qui parle avec son
cœur et s tripe c'est un Samaritain il
fait çaant VI fait il dit en VI dit et
ça ça c'est en règle que faut nous ni en
politique faut pas ni langage de bois
donc le progressisme du 21e siècle c'est
un progressisme qui doit évoluer et il
doit faire comme Emmanuel Macron
dépasser le jeu politique entre la
droite et la gauche c'est un acte de
défiance il n'y a pas de défiance
vis-à-vis de qui ah sera perçu comme ça
fr pe ch chacun interprète comme il veut
je ne suis pas dans l'interprétation je
suis là aujourd'hui comme vice-président
de l'Assemblée pour maintenir la
cohésion d'un groupe nous sommes 18 nous
portons un projet politique et dans ce
groupe il y a des personnes de droite il
y a des personnes du centre il y a des
personnes de gauche vous voulez
maintenir la cohésion d'un groupe tout à
fait vous êtes Sauveur si vous voulez me
présenter comme t mais je ne suis ni
Sauveur ni Messie je dis simplement
qu'il faut aujourd'hui que les mar Prenn
en compte cette nouvelle offre politique
d'Emmanuel Macron qui dit je suis le
candidat du travail il dit je veux
travailler sur le pouvoir d'achat des
martiniquain et je suis content
d'entendre dire qu'il y a une baisse des
impôts qui est annoncé pour les
contribuables du Sud il faut continuer
comme ça il faut pas qu'on augmente les
impôts tels qu'on les augmente à
saintte-marie Fred lordordino euh c'est
un soutien franc et massif au-delà de le
dire est-ce que par exemple à Emmanuel
Macron vous avez apporté officiellement
votre Sen tient un parinage par exemple
le parinage m'a été demandé et il y a
des fortes de fortes Chan queit Emmanuel
Macron l'obtienne ce n'est pas encore
fait mais je vous signale qu'il a plus
de 1000 parinages oui mais bon c'est
quand même un signe fort pour quelqu'un
qui la présiden je vous le répète je
vous le répète l'ISS l'issu pour les
progressistes martiniqu sera
certainement d'appeler à voter au second
tour pour Emmanuel Macron face à Marine
Le Pen et ça je voudrais que mes
compatriotes en soient conscient il y a
un risque aujourd'hui que nous ayons
dans la République française une
personne issue de l'extrême droite
dites-moi dites-moi il y en a d'autres
comme vous au sein de du Parti
progressiste martinble pour une
Martinique nouvelle qui veulent qui
veulent porter leur soutien franc et
massif comme vous ce matin à Emmanuel il
a obtenu déjà deux parinages en
Martinique il y a une femme et il y a un
maire de l'intérieur des terres il y a
plus que
deux officialement pour de est-ce qu'il
y en a d'autres qui risquent par exemple
dimanche soir à l'issue de de la primère
de la belle alliance populaire et Ben
qui vont se dire ben chalviront tout de
suite oui peut-être que d'ailleurs ce
weekend même nous allons lancer un appel
par le biais des médias martiniquis un
texte qui va appeler à se rassembler
autour des idées un collectif autour des
idées d'Emmanuel Macron je le répète
Macron c'est le candidat de la diversité
c'est le candidat du travail et
aujourd'hui ces idées correspondent à ce
que beaucoup de martiniica souhaitent
c'est pas un peu opportuniste tout cela
on vous sentez le vent souffler euh V
qui est en difficulté risquant de perdre
dimanche pas c'est une pratique c'est
une pratique que les progressistes du
Nord développent depuis plusieurs années
puisque ah l'opportunisme politique non
non le fait que nous dépassons le jeu
politique droite gauche moi j'ai soutenu
très clairement Christian Rafa et chacun
connais mes liens avec les époux petits
au Morn rouge je n'ai pas peur de cette
alliance avec la droite d'ailleurs je
vous dis il y a eu un événement en
Martinique en décembre 2015 il y a deux
voix pour les martiniquis il y a deux
voies aujourd'hui ils ils ont le choix
entre l'alliance des indépendantistes
avec la droite conservatrice ou bien ils
ont l'alliance
entreutomist
autom c'est unere coalition mais
aujourd'hui les deux camp principaux
intègr des élément de la droite et ça
vous pouvez pas faire comme si ça
n'existe
pas chercher des solutions
efficacesp publ efficace c'estàd est-ce
que des soins l'hôpital public est-ce
que situation bon est-ce que les petites
retraites est-ce que augmenter
c'est les notion philosophi de gauche ou
de droite ça c'est des politiques publi
efficace parce que retraite problème
puisque puis bien en maison et puisre
côté augmenter
donc
ile dit que c'est lu
FA est il n alors qu' est il n alors
qu'il est des mesures à prendre pour
permettre qu'il y ait plus de cohésion
et moins d'inégalité et Emmanuel Macron
lui il tient ce discours modernisateur
il dit aujourd'hui il faut remettre le
citoyen au cœur du débat politique il
veut rendre surtout les décision le
pouvoir de décision au territoire ça
vous parle ça exactement je suis
autonomiste et en ce sens qu'est-ce qui
il dit il veut bon on va pas utiliser un
langage trop technocratique mais il dit
c'est le principe de subsidiarité
c'est-à-dire que les problèmes nous les
réglons au niveau du territoire et il
dit si vous avez un projet de territoire
et que cela demande de nouvelles
compétences et bien nous allons les
financer lui en tant que chef d'État je
voudrais juste dire une chose concernant
par exemple les services de secours
lorsque l'État a transféré le service de
secours au département il y a pas eu de
transfert de ressources il y a eu un
transfert de charg et aujourd'hui on dit
aux gens dans les communes aux communes
payer le service de secours et bien nous
allons demander à Macron de financer les
services de secours en Martinique parce
qu'il faut aujourd'hui une recette pour
assurer l'équilibre des charges vous
vous mettez déjà en partenaire
privilégié d'Emmanuel Macron non non je
ne cherche pas de partenaire il a
privilégé ce que je cherche c'est les
mauvaises l que vous cherchez déjà à
vous positionner pour les législatives
pour d'autres combats en prenant
peut-être ce trait qu'on
annonce priste je suis nous sommes un
groupe nous sommes un groupe et moi je
dis progressiste nous sommes
progressiste nous resterons alors il met
également en avant Emmanuel Macron
l'identité enrichie il dit qu'il
fautoutenir les France les France c'est
vous avez bien
lu vous avez bien lu le projet
d'Emmanuel Macron il parle des France et
ce discours sur l'identité vous
l'autonomiste progressiste vous
retrouvez dans cette France qu'il faut
chérir qu'il faut préserver il parle des
Fran alors alors que tout le monde ne
parle que de la France donc c'est déjà
un progrès et vous savez êes composidé
l'idée l'idée dites-moi l'autonomiste le
progressiste que vous êtes avec le cœur
sur la main le progressiste dit je met
le cœur sur la main le prociste dit que
Emmanuel Macron reprend l'ensemble des
théories émises par
C sur l'identité alléluia alléluia pas
alléluia c'est la réalité parce
que monde qui a changé faut nous choisir
entre l'Amérique de Donald Trump et puis
les Chinois des communistes et celui qui
est le plus la Martinique de la chimie
mais c'est pas la chimie qui au pouvoir
nous sommes nous sommes des
progressistes il faut arrêter de
personnaliser les choses il faut
aujourd'hui vous imaginez Bienz fait
l'ORD vous comprenez bien que vos propos
ce matin vont provoquer quelques
réactions au sein de la machine
progressiste au sein d'ensemble pour une
Martinique nouvelle et auprès d'autres
martiniquet tout simplement qui sont des
observateurs de la vie politique mieux
parce faut pas que les gens restent chez
eux le jour du vote la progression de
l'abstention est inquiétante il faut que
les martiniicais s'impliquent dans la
vie politique de leur pays et donc si ça
peut interpeller cette émission y
compris dans mon propre parti et bien
j'aurais gagné mon Paris parce qu'il y a
des choses qui ne vont pas au sein du
parti poiste Martinique dans cette
parole dans ce débat ce besoin de
discuter de je vous dis que mon souci
principal c'est de maintenir l'unité et
la cohésion du groupe des 18 élus de la
minorité au sein de l'assemblée
territori
Fred lordordinau 4e vice-président de
l'Assemblée de
Martinique encore membre du Parti
progressiste Martinique et soutien
d'Emmanuel Macron candidat à la
présidentielle française merci d'avoir
été avec nous ce matin dans sacad bonne
journée merci bonne
journée